and my transgender should I transition
am I supposed to be a one-man Jeffrey
star admits he has thought about
transitioning and believes Kat Von D
started canceled culture the canceled
culture I feel like happened II was the
first person to jumpstart that and she
really tried to cancel me in a new
episode of the dish with Trish the 34
year old cosmetics CEO got completely
candid on the podcast with Trisha Paytas
here's what you need to know about
Jeffrey's first interview since drama
get in part 1 & 2 went down combining me
and Shane together something I'm just
like it made everything so much bigger
first up Jeffrey says his collaboration
with Shane Dawson quote changed his life
and led to the purchase of his fourteen
million dollar home I was already
planning on moving right yeah so then
it's just like we weren't gonna move
until next year because it conspiracy
just happened and then all of a sudden
you know life happens right Jeffery has
always pushed the boundaries when it
comes to gender norms and he opened up
to Tricia about feeling confused in his
own body like I had so many thoughts in
my head because I've always been really
feminine I didn't understand that could
be a male and wear makeup and and
feminine clothes and not be a woman I
was confused and how old were you when
you 20 yeah you know yes I'm 34 now and
I'm really comfortable in my skin and I
know I'm supposed to be like this is Who
I am but I was so confused and
conflicted back then so for you to to
question yourself why was there such an
outrage do people think you were
trolling the beauty guru also revealed
that at one point he actually thought
about releasing a sex tape with his
boyfriend Nate to build clout but his
growing status and a list clientele
brought that to a halt
i co-own Killer merge like I had all
these clients now like Kevin Hart
football players Shane and ninja and I
just don't know like the owner of the
brand should be like
online lastly Tricia teased Jeffrey
about his outspoken past telling fans he
once blocked her on social media because
she chimed in on the Kat Von D drama of
2016 her giving me advice about Kat Von
D she still alive back story Kat accused
Jeffrey who had been her friend for 10
years at the time of unpaid wages to an
artist friend who she claimed helped
create the jeffree star cosmetics logo
and fans went nuts I've never had a
friendship analyze in front of an
audience like that one there's so much
to it and she really tried to cancel me
and it didn't work and it was obviously
a bunch of Lies and I debunked them all
right back then it was so crazy to wake
up and experience no one asking
hey what about what's his side what's
what does he have to say just full kill
yourself die you're the devil and I was
like I had never experienced that I'm
gonna hate before in such like volume
[Music]